are you going to the draft I am okay
yeah are you nervous that you might sit
there for a little while and then the
cameras on you as we've seen in previous
drafts not at all
you know my dream is always to be in
that green room and this is my once
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity so I'm
gonna take advantage of it and go what
do you know about your future right now
you have any idea what's going to happen
Thursday not at all I mean you hear so
many different things but uh I mean from
all the advice I've gotten from each
east team I visit with or without wit
they all for sure everybody loved you
yeah the office sure said I'm going
first round so hopefully if they stand
up put would you tell me if you knew
where you were going I would give you a
hint but I have no head it's
Jacksonville chance at four I'm pretty
um I think so I mean they brought me
down to visit the visit went great spent
a lot of time I got a form of course I
was like Clemson with me is there in
Jacksonville oh so uh so that's a chance
that's a real chair that doesn't saying
because I didn't think of Jacksonville I
thought Kansas City would be a great
spot for you right
Oh in my Kansas City and read and anyway
it's good yeah yeah it would be nice do
you want to go in and learn are you okay
with going in and then sitting and
watching I'm okay with it I think it's a
great value coming from learning from a
veteran guy that's been there done that
know how to have a success and adversity
and know how to be a professional you
know how the team operates but I also
I'm curious about this when somebody
says why you got to be able to take
stamps from centre-right okay
how many times did you take Samsung
Center at Clemson during Pratt as we did
but as far as game other than you know
affirmation short yardage are not really
too much but do we make too big of a
deal of what that means when you take
the ball from under center and you have
to draw back as opposed to just being in
shotgun I mean it's a little different
but if you really break down the NFL
game majority understand story shotgun
you're going to be in shotgun you want
to because of how good the front line is
the defensive line are you want to buy
yourself more time so you don't want to
start up there where they at and give
them extra time to make a play so you
want to get a shotgun
who's the quarterback that you look at
in the NFL and you say I sort of pattern
myself after him uh it's kind of hard to
I feel like each quarterback is
different but if I had a pick you're not
like to Sean Kaiser you have a mind of
Tom Brady's body Cam Newton not at all
but if I had to pick I say uh I wish
though don't we all yeah that's all
right don't want taken and MVP but FATA
paid probably Marcus Mariota or Russell
Wilson those two guys is what's your
official heightened like official that
the come out was six two and a half to
twenty one but are you almost too short
like is there a number there if you were
under six two then you're too short
right I'm pretty sure right that's the
way it goes yeah but there's no like
there's no difference in you know what a
half inch here or an inch not the way
you play not at all you see that you
still I mean you might feel a little bit
over the line but maybe if you're six
seven or six six and you can't really
throw you can't move and then you have a
city got to see it to feel better than
you and can make better decisions and
it's kind of so sighs and now that's and
all the body type is kind of given going
out the window nowadays what did you
make of the Wonderlic scores being made
public you I guess in a you go both ways
you know some people say that they'd
rather just keep it closed and let the
team's know stead of that in the whole
world now because you know they some
people scored low on that and don't test
well but have a great career and some
people do the opposite so I said how
goofy is that like what are some of the
questions you it's kind of weird
questions it's kind of like you know Bob
have you know 36 cucumbers or apples and
Sam has 18 and that's the amount that
comes and take twelve from Bob and she
adds something is a Sabrina and the
clock is running so you just like wait
what
and then you just gotta really just kind
of basically choose and a pig how does
that help you on 3rd and 10 against
Alabama I guess see how quick you can
operate in process I'm gonna sue Sykes
explain your success against Alabama
you know I'm always big on challenges
and so uh you know whenever does the
challenge is there in my face and the
bigger the challenge the better I play
and perform and you know Alabama just
brings the best out of youth and either
gonna get exposed are you going to
expose them and I will they talk trash
to util they try to butt in like what
are they son everything I mean just kind
of get on my face every day you know
giving in the under the PAL and just
shot up just nagging Charlie give me off
my game what were they doing in the pond
they grabbed it not really grabbing but
they're just like you know kind of
chipping me late different things like
that trying to take my head off but but
then it wasn't gonna bother me what did
that mean we are you more likely to
watch the game you want against Alabama
or the game you lost probably the game
with one because you know I want to feel
I don't want to feel that loss and think
about that loss because it's really when
make up for that loss they do okay do
they do but honestly man the the when we
lost it felt like we want at the same
time it's kind of weird because so many
people were surprised how well we played
and how they thought that we should have
won the game and you know going into the
best season everyone was like okay it's
gonna be close to Alabama and then us
championship again which it was but I
just felt like we have so much respect
so much you know recognition from that
game give me the play of the game
winning touchdown against Alabama so
guys we're in the huddle
Orlando okay here we go there we go
nicoleff our nickel right we'll rope
crush so nickel is their formation yes
it's empty formation we'll pull it back
in and then rope is the protection and
it crushes the concept blob was it on
two or guys I want I want okay
go in it but what's that what's that
like when you see as you release you
have somebody wide open right and you
know what's at the end of that is a if
you're not melodious yeah pretty much
it was slow motion and just kind of
writing a hit of everything just sped up
again and it was uh you know you have
times and practice where you kind of
have open guy throw it at his feet but
that that moment I was ago not happen
deshaun Watson the former Clemson
quarterback is joining us on behalf of
Old Spice hardest-working collection
look at you already getting paid nice I
like that yeah I could do so what are
you doing with Old Spice here uh yeah
I'm partner blow spice for the draft and
uh just making sure that you know get me
prepared for the the bait day
now you can't sweat on Thursday night I
know that's why I have Old Spice okay
I'll have a go slice this is the hydrate
wash body wash that made sure that my
skin is hydrated and I'm feeling good
smelling good and then I have of course
the deodorant that makes you know not
sweat whenever the pressures on I'm
nervous I like that I like that you're
ready to go what did you major in
communications
oh so you're ready you were ready for
this man I'm ready for this moment so
hopefully coming to broadcasting is that
what a little bit I was up to some
classes with broadcasting yeah but what
do you want to do with communications
I'm not sure it's so broad you can do so
many date probably this you know after
football I could join your show
yeah but I'm Tom Brady here let me I'm
Newton body has you beat Auburn
I don't care unit servers right I'm
gonna be on the guests you're the host
so this is welcome to the Shawn Watson
program here all right welcome to the
Cheryl Watson show yeah and we have a
man Dan Patrick here yeah and uh we're
going to talk about the dress okay so
today you know we're you know you have
guys that you know you see all these
mock drafts in the quarterbacks you play
quarterback yeah and you see how these
mock jobs saying the quarterbacks will
go first round
it was gonna stake around what should or
should take it was your input on that I
don't think there's a starter in the
draft I don't think somebody goes in and
starts right away if I'm a quarterback
and I am I want to be drafted a little
bit later on in the first round I want
to go to a better team a better system
better coach a team that wins as opposed
to going in and trying to be a savior
I'm a sense made sense yeah we have one
wrote one word going into the NFL what
would that word be
stallion I think I think that's pretty
much the
it always comes to mind that's Britney
deshaun Watson show here I I do like
Kansas City I said that Jacksonville I
think's a wild-card there could you play
in New York with the Jets though given
what New York's all about you come from
a small town right like Clemson in a
small town not and you did well on the
big stage right right how would you do
with New York mom what would mom think
of you being in New York she wouldn't
mind that my brother is in New York Jets
fan so he would love it oh wow he was I
was wrong with your brother yeah he
loves the Jets but uh it would be
different it would be a new a new task a
challenge but I think I can right I you
can sleep here in the man cave for the
first couple of weeks if you need to
nice guys like there a nice little crib
we got here oh yeah we got at the
kitchen now now we have a challenge for
you coming up I don't think you did this
at the combine
now I have now that is from the Mardi
Gras float that we had in New Orleans at
the Super Bowl so that's my head over
there I need you to dent my nose all
right and this is going to be about from
20 yards away okay are you capable of
doing that I can do that now what if you
miss your stock could go down you may
drop out of the first round if you
missed this and we find that I pulled
their car oh I like second round I like
that well done see all right so during
the live look in two throws per deshaun
Watson to see if he can hit me right on
if you can hit your target right on the
nose okay give me another plug here for
Old Spice we loved working with those
folks just no spices is great keeping me
fresh keeping you fresh and if you can
just go to the YouTube o spice YouTube
page and learn more about it by the way
you took 2150 snaps over the last two
seasons you know how many were taken
under center maybe 2046 or taken under
center just let you know ninety seven
point nine percent of the time you were
in a shotgun formation so there you go
with our deshaun Watson stat of the day
we're back to Sean we'll put on an
aerial display we'll see if he can get
my nose from 20 yards out good luck on
Thursday night is their appreciation by
the way I did vote for you for the
Heisman thank you yeah thank you sorry
about that it didn't work yeah they're
not better right now I have the ring we
almost did it
Oh oh wait you don't have your ring with
you I live my mom got him oh she does
you do see Cuba man see how if you could
have the Heisman or the ring I'm
thinking a ring okay okay so we're at
the wise choice
that's the wise choice right there all
right deshaun Watson will come back
after this damn Patrick Hill two throws
okay I'll be back
Rose are you lunatic now we were
thinking of having a defender rush
toward you just to say to you know make
you feel at home without ollie could be
the defender all right
so right on the tip of my nose all right
now you ready we're doing on one because
I like to get it going all right cool
okay I like eyebrows that dent in my
forehead
I'll get one more this is this is right
here for the national title and a chance
to be drafted by the Jets Holly wants to
know what's the rule let me think you
could hit a moving target DeSean
tomorrow all right here we go what can
go wrong here you ready okay
[Laughter]
good luck I hate a good boy
thank you guys I was very fun this is
what we actually do this is a real show
rockin Christine accept all the best you
this is what we actually did I was a lot
of fun they'll be able to bring that
back yeah all right
boy he was locked in I mean that was
pretty accurate yeah
it was right the the head went back into
my headed back down the floor thank you
guys thank you thank you good luck with
Old Spice is there the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience